the notion of Randomness which in
science has been very highly developed
has been imported into our individual
lives without too much reflection upon
it and the fact is that we uh
our lives are very densely plotted
and we are not behaving stochastically
randomly without order and the things
that happen to us the people that cross
our path are in retrospect by most
people and by psychedelic people in
Prospect
seen as somehow intended
structured
archetectonically laid out an example of
this that's always impressed me was I
years and years ago in the orient at
Angkor I met this couple
and he had been a very large LSD dealer
in the hate and had made sufficient
money that his life's goal had been to
find out if there was anything in the
world that worked better than his LSD
and so we fell at my friend I was
traveling with a dear friend of mine we
fell in with these people and they were
on their way to India as were we and
once in Bombay my friend and I were
scheduled to catch a boat to the
Seychelles Islands where I was going I
had been there the year before and I was
going back to buy real estate well so we
told these people about the Seychelles
and how wonderful
they were and so they changed their
plans decided not to go to the ashram
that they had staked out and rishikesh
decided instead to go with us to the
Seychelles Islands which we dutifully
did and to
well there were many many weird things
about this trip but anyway we land in
the Seychelles Islands where they had
never been before and there's a long
long pier the British East India steam
navigation company liners that plied
that route at that time there was no
airport there then
were had such a deep draft that they
couldn't actually come into Shore so you
had to transfer by shore boats to this
long pier
so we have all our baggage and
everything and to transfer to the pier
and we're walking down this pier and
it's this recessional Vista with this
beautiful little tropical town with
corrugated roofs and bending Palms lying
at the end of it and these truly
spectacular Granite Pinnacles behind it
the highest point in the Seychelles is
about
2400 feet feet and it's attained within
300 yards of the beach
so what we're talking about is just a
tooth of black stone that rises up and
the Seychelles are at 43 seconds South
less than a degree south of the Equator
so there's this tremendous buildup of
atmospherics daily thunderstorms
downpours rainbows and all this was
going on uh as we disembarked the ship
and we're carrying everybody's each
carrying a suitcase walking into this
rainbow waterfall environment and far
far down this pier we see these there's
two people two disheveled figures with
the gauntedness of morphine addiction
and too long upon the road
and as we get closer and closer to these
people you see that they are noticing us
and finally the the man begins to run
toward us
and he runs up to my friend the guy I
met at Encore the guy of the couple that
we had convinced to come with us to the
Seychelles
and they say
I'll change the guy's name they say Neil
Neil my God it's you it's really you and
the guy said I who I uh I don't know you
who are you and he said you don't know
me you don't know me
look at me
said I I don't he said don't you
remember three years ago in ten years we
got stoned together the night before you
were going back to the States and he
said well wait a minute
I was in Tangiers three years ago I
remember getting stoned in a hotel room
with a room full of people before I went
and he said yes don't you remember what
you told me I said no
what did I tell you he said you told us
that the game was running in Kenya and
that we should change all our plans that
we should give up going to Istanbul that
we should give up going the Overland
route to Asia and that we should go
south into Africa we've been with the
tribes for three years and he lifted up
his shirt and his whole chest was
scarified and he and he said you told us
that Africa would transform our lives
and the guy and my friends said yeah
[Laughter]
did it
and and he said yes yes it did and it
was and so it was very clear
that
my friends rap which had been given
almost unconsciously which it was just
you know the end of the third joint he
was the best traveled person in this
hotel room he laid out a bunch of advice
and not realizing that these two people
who we later found out had escaped from
Mental Hospitals in the United States
and were hiding out in 10 years it had
fallen upon them like God's holy writ
that he was the psychopomp he was
telling them what to do and they're
entire they had stories that would stand
your Heron in they had been with the
Maasai drinking blood and milk they had
moved on to the to EU that's where the
scarification had taken place that she
had been part of various harems he had
been lion hunting he had been mauled by
a lion I mean they were hard traveled
characters
and
and it had to do with taking this rap
seriously and implementing it so I just
was an observer to this whole thing
fortunately because it could have been
me it was you because your friend had
been on his way to somewhere else and
you had just sideswiped him into the
station two true too true
I I had deflected his path and he had
deflected their paths and now he had to
reap the karma of his advice because the
Seychelles were so small a place that
immediately we were for an item and
these people were welded on to our lives
in the minds of the immigration
officials and the police and so forth
because up to that point no one had
dared even approached them and we were
spotted embracing conversing and going
to dinner with them so it really made us
part of their world well the point of
that story is the power of language the
power of language uh
to make reality and our need to take it
more seriously because your words set
Cascades of events in motion I really
feel this because people say to me
you think I should do one gram or five
and I realize you know that we're
standing in some kind of really odd node
where they don't know what they're
asking but an answer is being sought and
it will be acted upon
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]